[Music]
the first video was
all about carefully study the graphs of
continuous
and discontinuous functions feel free to
check it out
but now what if i give you a function in
an algebraic form
and ask you to check whether it's
continuous or not
at say x equal to one
one way to find out would be to neatly
sketch its graph to scale
if we know how to and this graph will
give us the answers
but sketching a graph takes time and
anyways this is not normally how we do
it
although one can always use the
graphical method for verification
in the end but conventionally we check
the continuity at a point by using the
algebraic definition of continuity
okay we will come back to this example
some other time
in this video our focus will be purely
on
understanding this definition the
definition reads as
a function f is continuous at a point c
in the domain
if left and right hand limits at c are
equal to each other
as well as equal to f of c
it looks slightly convoluted but it's
actually not difficult to work with the
examples
if you know how to evaluate limits
but first we will try to understand its
abstract structure
through a nice but effective bit of
reasoning
now let's say that we have some function
f defined for all real numbers
and let's say we want to check its
continuity at a real number c
we don't know anything about this
function or its graph
to comment anything about continuity at
c
but one thing that we can all agree upon
is a simple logical fact
that f can either be continuous or
discontinuous at c
it cannot be both or neither
here's a question for you then if
suppose
f is discontinuous at c then what will
happen to the graph of the function
at that particular c this is a graph of
a discontinuous function
that we'd seen in the last video we
observe
discontinuity at three points x1
x2 and x3 the point
x1 comma f of x1 on the graph is not
connected with the part of the graph on
its left
this point is not connected with the
part of the graph on its right
while this point is disjoint from both
the left
as well as the right partitions
the similar argument can be modeled for
our function
f if it's discontinuous at a point
the point c comma f of c no matter where
it lies on this vertical line
it will not be connected with either the
part of the graph
on the left side or on the right side or
even
both and this is irrespective of what
the graphs are on the left
and the right and as said earlier
irrespective of where this point lies
so now what will be the opposite of this
argument for a continuous function
yes if f is a continuous function at c
then the point c comma f of c will be
connected to the parts on both sides
at least up to some extent in the
neighborhood
again it does not matter what the graphs
are on either side
or where the function is defined at c on
this vertical line
it can either be a piecewise function
defined differently on either sides of c
or it can be given by a single nice and
smooth relation
in that particular neighborhood either
way
we're guaranteed that as long as the
graphs on either sides are connected to
c comma
f of c function is continuous
at c also
we can't predict anything about how long
this connection will
extend on either sides but theoretically
we're assured that point c comma f of c
will be connected with the graphs on
either side in some neighborhood
around the point no matter how tiny or
huge that neighborhood is on either side
so that's a neat way to conceptualize
the continuity at a point
the math in the definition specifies
this very notion
of connectedness in the language of
limits
here's how to bring in a little more
clarity in the explanation
assume this is how the graph of f looks
like in the vicinity around
point c take any variable x
close to c in its left neighborhood also
mark
f of x on the y axis since the graph is
connected between
these two points in this neighborhood as
x
approaches c f of x will approach
f of c in the language of limits
this means limit of f of x as x
approaches c minus is f of c
minus sign indicates that we're
approaching c
from the left hand side similarly
we take a variable x in the neighborhood
now to the right of c
and again since these two points are
connected
here as well limit of f of x as x
approaches c
plus will be f of c plus
sign over c is an indication that x
approaches c from the right
so all in all if a function is
continuous at c
both its left hand limit and the right
hand limit at c
will always be equal to the value of the
function at c
this implies that the normal limit limit
of
f of x as x approaches c
is equal to f of c
and that is the most bookish definition
of continuity
now obviously the converse of the
statement is also true
if a function satisfies this at a point
it
is continuous at that point starting
from the next video
we will start seeing a few examples to
determine continuity of functions
at points so i hope
after this video the definition of
continuity makes more sense
by now you would have realized that
we're going to need the knowledge of
limits
to study continuity hence
i invite you to watch our video series
on limits
i'll see you in the next video goodbye
till then